this is what's left of Alba and Andy's
house the rest of it he's down here
he built the home for his retirement
here in Brazzaville erosion took it away
along with much of his neighborhood this
area it's a serious problem I had a
large family here and now I'm forced to
rent but I am not paid my pension so I
have to stay with a neighbor I can't
even find money to feed myself it's a
similar story in several parts of the
city the Republic of Congo's capital
people say the government has done
nothing the sand in the slopes around
the city was once held together by trees
they've been cut down as the population
grows but the erosion problem keeps
growing - this place has already been
abandoned this one will be abandoned
soon but the problem is people have
nowhere else to go
but it's not the same for everyone
luxury apartment in the Trump
International Hotel and Tower in New
York cost millions of dollars
anti-corruption investigators Global
Witness say one was bought with stolen
Congolese public money for seven million
the nearly 40-year rule of Congolese
president deneece a su ingresso has been
blighted with corruption scandals Global
Witness says it was his daughter Claudia
seen here standing next to him who
bought the New York apartment a
spokesman for the first family declined
to comment on the allegations Congo and
billions of dollars every year from oil
exports Global Witness says it's traced
tens of millions of dollars of stolen
revenues a mansion in this suburb of
Paris is among around 20 properties
belonging to members of the first family
that French prosecutors are
investigating along with other purchases
including more than a million dollars
spent on suits and shirts from this shop
in Brazzaville it's easy to find
pictures of presidents a su and Gresso
on the street it's harder to find anyone
who'll criticize him or his government
but a handful of activists meet every
week they tried to hold the government
to account for corruption and rights
abuses
it's risky work this is the most recent
member of their group to be imprisoned
he's accused of threatening state
security their leader Joe Abena says
it's all to hide a simple truth how
would you explain it what this country
is support it's just cause of the
leadership the leadership is so corrupt
that the country is down
so here is it is stealing this money
well the President and do all people
that is in power activists say it's
through an elaborate international money
laundering network that congos wealth
ends up being spent on luxuries abroad
like the apartment in New York the Trump
Organization says it has no connection
to that deal and didn't own the
apartment when it was sold for people
living in Brazzaville suburbs just a
fraction of Congo's missing millions
could help save their homes from falling
apart
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera Brazzaville
Republic of Congo